stop asking us what to do how to fix
things I'm so tired of all the
conversations all of us want to be
working and not having to come and do
panels and speeches this is a
great thing it's good that we're talking
about it we have to keep talking about
it
but you wonder why there's no indigenous
stuff out there this is the
making us come and talk about the
problem and tell you how to fix it you
broke it you fix it it's like
someone coming into your house stealing
all your and burning your house
down and then saying now
you're going to rebuild your house and
what can we give you to help you rebuild
your house that we burnt down you build
a house and I'll come back and
hopefully you get it right and if you
don't get it right then we'll try again